Film Courage: What were the top three things would
you say from the production standpoint
that were the toughest she said that was
where most of the problems? Co-Writer/Producer, Nadia Jordan:  Yeah, I mean
you know financing is always hard this
they started with a crowdfunding
campaign and grew and you know said we
had some initial funding come in but we
we were given deadlines and we kept
getting this deadline extended and I
needed to get more money in or we were
going to lose the funding we had so that
was a huge stress it was like a year and
or over a year of trying to raise more
money to actually you know be able to
shoot the film and for me as a producer
it was something you know this was new
territory to me I'd produce but I hadn't
gone out and raised money for a feature
before so you know and in LA everyone's
got a film that they think is great that
they're trying to get made so that was
really hard particularly because he had
these deadlines and at some point you
have to and you know I went to a lot of
producer seminars and people like you
know whatever budget you've got however
small have a big you're always gonna
want more just just shoot just shoot
scale it down do something but don't let
someone go especially in this position
where we had some money you know I
wasn't sure if we could make the film
for that but it got to the point where I
just had to go for it and and you know
that was at the point I decided to
produce it myself but the deadlines were
hard like we had a deadline we didn't
have a director I really wanted to phim
our director which is also proving hard
I think we've got a female director in
the November we were starting shooting
in the January February and I we got her
I think maybe September but it was
November she had to pull out so it was
you know it was November we were
shooting in two months and we had no
director so I met with a lot of
directors China you know trying to get
someone who could shoot within that time
frame and that was really hard like what
do we do now like I really wanted a
female director to kind of keep with the
whole theme of you know we had female
writers female producers it was a female
driven driven script
I felt that it really needed a female
director not that I have anything
against male directors at all but for
this particular project I thought you
know it's a it's like a hole filled with
female filmmaker you know it just felt
right but
it was a struggle because there aren't a
whole lot of them out there and the ones
that were were busy or couldn't couldn't
work within the deadline so that was a
big stress and then you know there's all
kinds of stuff that came up in post we
had a big problem with sound not because
of anything bad to do with the sounds on
the film but with the post sound like
when someone who started who couldn't
finish went to another sound studio so
that took about eight months longer than
it should have done so it was just you
know it was just that there were things
that came up the whole time from a
producing standpoint like I don't know I
mean that the thing that wasn't so hard
was distribution really no because we
got to the point I I approached a lot of
distributors and vision films our
distributor I'd heard a lot of good
things about and went to them and it
works out pretty well but of course it
was a stress to me because at that point
I made a film I didn't know how easy it
was going to be to get distribution so
yeah there were a lot of a lot of things
that you know roadblocks that we had to
cross along the way and you mentioned
briefly about people dropping out and I
think that's interesting thing about LA
I think people have great intentions you
know and they don't mean to flake some
of them yeah maybe they don't care but I
think a lot of people want to keep their
word but for whatever reason they don't
and so how was that did you have to
recast or or add new people in in the
last minute yeah I mean it began with a
producer who I was gonna work with who
you know had got funding and you know
turned out he hadn't got funding but you
know these people you know this to me
starting very early on and it was
someone actually I knew and so that was
something that was the first one that I
hit like you know just be honest you
know just if you haven't got the money
great we can work together but you know
so there was that kind of thing and then
there was a director that I was gonna
work with but it was you know everyone's
kind of hedges their bets it's like
unless it's your own project like yeah
yeah I want to do your for it yeah it's
we have you got the money yet now okay
well when you get the money and then
it's like you know well I'm not really
gonna work with it I want a job I'll be
employed and help you but you have to do
all the work and then if I think if it's
going to be successful then I might jump
on so it was really hard to find people
that were really passionate and
committed
and that would be great to work with and
stay the course that you know because
there is always going to be bigger
better projects so you want someone to
become and actually that was something
that happens was during filming we had a
couple of crew members drop out to go
and work on big-budget movies so our
line producer was constantly you know
trying to find new lighting trying to
fighting that was something we lost
actually we lost one of our gaffers
during filming and we were desperately
trying to find another one and because
people don't want to commit but you know
we had a lot of people that were really
great that were really committed that we
couldn't have made this film without but
it was you know there was a few people
along the way that I thought were going
to be great to work with but you know
other things come along and basically
like I say if it's not their project the
commitments just not always there
sometimes it's surprising the ones that
seem so committed or you know
overzealous in the beginning or maybe
that's the wrong word but and they're
the ones that actually drop out and ones
that don't you you you you're not even
sure of and then they actually stay the
course that's surprising yeah and it's
really nice you know I've met people on
this film like crew and and post you
know post-production people that I will
definitely go on and work with on my
next film you know there's some really
good people out there it's just you know
it's it's just who you gel with and you
know who gets it and who you know
commitment is a big thing right yeah
well there's so many things in LA too
that are going on and people also have
other jobs or whatever so I know that's
one of the issues that yeah we did
actually have them one of the one of the
leads one of the other lead actresses
and we had someone commit for four
months and then they pulled out so we
had to rehearse though there was a
little bit of that going on but not too
much with E with the actresses because
we cast really close to filming so you
know everyone kind of knew by them what
their schedules were there was one role
Ruth Connell who plays the role of
Stacey she was initially meant to play
the role of Sharon the editor but she
was filming on supernatural so she had a
friend Marina Sirtis who now plays
Sharon the editor who's from Star Trek
next generation so she got
to fill in for her role actually so that
was another thing that I created later
for Ruth the role of Stacey was not
written into the original script but
Ruth is great friends of mine a great
actress and I really wanted her involved
so those scenes actually came later the
role of Stacey that we went and shot
after the initial 15 day shoot because
Ruth was committed to supernatural at
the time
you